is it a crisis
or just a challenge at the border the
white house going off message today
about the situation before they had to
walk it back
take a look that they would be partners
in dealing with the crisis on the border
you said crisis on the border
is is that a uh challenges on the border
okay but so that's not that doesn't
reflect any change
in no administration's view of things
nope
that happening after president biden got
called out by his own border officials
they claim he's denying reality of
what's happening
those same officials warning they're
being overwhelmed and don't have the
resources to handle thousands of
children
coming into the country dubai the
administration also under fire for not
letting the media
into migrant facilities agents
reportedly feel like they're
quote under a gag order and the white
house being called out for lack of
transparency
and you all came in and promised to be
the most truthful
and transparent administration and you
all you know
oversee the department of homeland
security so if you all wanted to grant
access to the press couldn't you just
tell dhs to do it
again we fully support transparency and
i would encourage you to talk to the
department of homeland security about
any requests you have for press access
or
what you're looking to accomplish at the
border the white house and we all in the
administration
support finding a way to grant access to
the media
to the hhs and or facilities or the
shelters where
these children are are staying for a
temporary period of time
uh kennedy let me begin with you uh jan
saki's use of the word
crisis as you just saw there it's being
seen as a big deal by
critics of the biden administration's
border policy
my question to you does it change
anything in terms of the reality of what
the what we're dealing with at the
border
the reality that i'm most concerned with
is the reality of the children
who i i don't care what you call it i
don't care if you call them detention
centers i don't care if you call them
cages
i don't care if you call it a crisis i
don't care if you call it a challenge
but at least care about the kids seem
like you're caring about the kids
instead of just caring about words
and as far as access there are two
things that will
sink any administration aside from a
pandemic
that's a big immigration crisis and
tax policy failure and biden could be on
a fast track to both we're not talking
about taxes right now so let's talk
about
immigration these pictures are awful the
reality for these children is awful but
you're not seeing that because
they are not granting access and cbp and
dhs
are both saying that they are not
allowed to take journalists on
ride-alongs
ride-alongs are critical for knowing how
law enforcement local and federal works
and it's also critical for telling the
story of these children who are arriving
by themselves
with no end in sight
so jesse this kind of surge of
underage immigrants happens every few
years under republicans as well as
democrats
i wonder if we can agree that both
republicans and democrats
see more advantage in blaming president
trump or
blaming president biden than they are in
solving the problem
this is shaping up to be a record surge
of unaccompanied minors
and everybody cares about that if you're
a republican or you're a democrat
but the crisis box the democrats are in
they built that box remember for the
last several years
they've slapped the crisis label on
everything to justify
extreme and immediate action remember
the climate crisis we have to spend
a hundred trillion dollars that we're
all gonna die a constitutional crisis
we have to impeach trump immediately a
covid crisis we have to spend
350 billion to bail out the blue states
so they've done that to themselves
remember rahm emanuel says never let a
crisis go to waste
finally the democrats have found a
crisis that they don't mind
wasting time confronting because
they don't want to they have the tools
to address it
joe biden can come out right now and
reinstitute the remain
in mexico policy he could strong-arm the
mexican government
to force the mexican military to stop
the caravans he could expel
the 16 and 17 year old unaccompanied
minors who were coming here
he could stop the catch and release he
could finish the border wall
so you don't leave a mile of open space
to come into
all of those things he could do juan to
your point he could even
demand that congress not do
comprehensive immigration reform
but just single out the asylum fix and
he could fax
track that right away and that would
stop the entire search
but he's not doing that because that
would mean he would have to take
action and he's too afraid of his
radical open borders left wing base
to be seen to be doing anything that
might be similar to what donald trump
did even though that was actually
effective in letting those people
remain in mexico or central america and
apply for asylum in their home countries
like everybody else has done now he's
playing this rhetorical game with the
press
to buy time so he doesn't have to take
action
it's not what adults do adults solve
problems
they don't mess around and play word
games and i'm surprised
the president's what nearly 80 act like
an adult
solve the problem all right so dana
today president biden tweeted out
support for two house bills i think
they're going to get voted on today both
dealing with immigration
one on the dreamers one-on-farm workers
both popular with the american people
and biden asked congress to come
together here i'm quoting to find
long-term solutions for the immigration
system
you think there's any hope dana that
they actually would get something done
this is a this is a classic way that the
democrats do this right so
they'll wait till there's a crisis they
don't know how to solve it and then
they'll say
why aren't the republicans coming up
with solutions well they had solutions
and then you took you decided to go in a
different direction
lindsey graham the senator from south
carolina said that he could support
i don't want to put words in his mouth
but there are ideas on immigration
reform that he would be willing to
support
but he says the border security issue
has to be one that you deal with
and they're going to demand that it's
dealt with first and the white house
press secretary she doesn't
need my help but this is what i think um
there's a meme on twitter referring to
the white house chief of staff as the
prime minister
prime minister claine yesterday he held
a meeting with a congressional
congressional progressive caucus
basically promised them the sun the moon
and the stars
that when they start to do
infrastructure you bet we're going to
throw all of these things on there
meantime his press secretary is going
out there every single day
taking on endless water unable to figure
out how to save herself from this
rhetorical situation that they put
themselves in
and to me they should just rip the
band-aid off it is a crisis
move on or they're not going to be able
to do to deal with the fact that
they have a fact problem causing a
communications problem
but their communications problem
initially from the campaign
has caused their fact problem the sooner
they deal with that the sooner they'll
be able to deal with somebody else and i
would say that the white house chief of
staff or the prime minister
the communications director where susan
rice where is anybody to help her
or even the president of the united
states she's taking on water
just go ahead and call it a crisis it'll
be over within 24 hours and then you can
move on to actually try
to deal with the actual substance and
not just this crisis
challenge story
so greg in fact picking up on what
dana's talking about you have 20
centrist
senators bipartisan republican democrat
coming together saying
we're looking for solutions in terms of
immigration in terms of infrastructure
and beyond health care now but i don't
see schumer the
the democratic leader in the senate i
don't see mcconnell the republican
leader getting behind these people
why not it's a great question i right
now i just feel bad
for jen sackey i mean after that press
conference i heard her brother called
afterwards and said
don't cry sis anyway you guys are
missing
in my view there's a really really big
story going on regarding immigration and
but it's going on outside of this our
outside of this show right now if you if
you turn on any other channel
viewers are being sold the idea that
america is the land of white supremacy
yet right now we are seeing thousands
tens of thousands and it will be
millions of non-white people
risking life in limb to come to america
why would they do that if they believed
what they saw on cnn
that we are a nation of racists why are
they coming
because they know that it's not true
they are
actually literally voting with their
feet
which is destroying the big lie about
what this country is the big lie that's
being sold to americans by cnn
and other media outlets america they
believe is the land of opportunity
not the land of white racism and that is
tearing
a massive hole in the in the white
power narrative that is being played
24 7. the bottom line about immigration
a country has to be able to dictate its
borders that's obvious
other countries can't dictate your
border by having for
large numbers of people go to it yet we
have to control it
they have to control theirs but i want
the people to come here
that want to be here with me that makes
me feel good
it makes me feel good because they're
validating our country they're
validating our values
and they crush the central fallacy
of woke identity politics that this
country is forever stained with white
supremacy
because there are people that we're
seeing right now on the border
who blast that idea all to hell and that
should make
everybody happy and it's why other
networks
aren't covering this story because it
destroys all the other stories they're
doing
all right